do you think people are inherently good
or do we all have good and evil in us
that
basically everyone is capable of evil
based on the environment certainly most
of us have
potential for both good and evil i'm not
prepared to say that everyone is capable
of evil
maybe some people who even in the worst
of circumstances would not be capable of
it
but most of us are very susceptible to
environmental influences
so when we look at things that we were
talking about previously let's say that
what the nazis did during the holocaust
i think it's quite difficult to say
i know that i would not have done those
things
even if i were in the same circumstances
as those
who did them even if let's say i had
grown up
under the nazi regime and had been
indoctrinated with
racist ideas had also
had the the idea that i must obey orders
follow the
commands of the fewer plus of course
perhaps the threat that if i didn't do
certain things
i might get sent to the russian front
and that would be a pretty
grim fate i think it's really hard for
anybody to say
nevertheless i know i would not have
killed those jews or
whatever else it was that though what's
your intuition how many people will be
able to say that
truly to be able to say it i think very
few
no less than 10 to me it seems a very
interesting and powerful thing to
meditate on so i've read a lot about the
war
the world war ii and i can't escape the
thought that i would have not
been one of the ten percent right
i have to say i simply don't know um i i
would like to hope that i would
have been one of the 10 but i don't
really have any basis for
claiming that i would have been
different from the majority
um is it a worthwhile thing to
contemplate
it would be interesting if we could find
a way of really finding these answers
there obviously is quite a bit of
research on
people during the holocaust on how
ordinary germans got
led to do terrible things and there's
there are also studies of the resistance
some
heroic people in the white rose group
for example who
resisted even though they knew they were
likely to die for it
um but i don't know whether these
studies really
can answer your larger question of how
many people would have been
capable of doing that well
sort of the reason i think it's
interesting is in the world
as you described you know when
when uh there are things that you would
like to do that are good
that are objectively good it's
useful to think about whether i'm not
willing to do something
or i don't even i'm not willing to
acknowledge something as
good and the right thing to do because
i'm simply scared of
putting my life of damaging my life in
some kind of way
and that kind of thought exercise is
helpful to understand what is what is
the right thing in my
current skill set and the capacity to do
so if there's things that are convenient
and there's
i wonder if there are things that are
highly inconvenient or i would have to
experience derision
or hatred or or death or all those kinds
of things but it's truly the right thing
to do and that kind of balance is
uh i feel like in america we don't have
it's it's difficult to think in the
current times
it seems easier to put yourself back in
history
where you can sort of objectively
contemplate whether
how willing you are to do the right
thing when the cost is high
true but i think we do face those
challenges today and i think
uh we can still ask ourselves those
questions
so one stand that i took more than 40
years ago now was to stop eating meat
and become a vegetarian at a time when
you hardly met anybody who was a
vegetarian or if you did they might have
been a hindu
or they might have had some weird
theories about meat and health
and i i know thinking about making that
decision i was convinced that it was the
right thing to do but i still did have
to think
are all my friends going to think that
i'm a crank um because i'm now
refusing to eat meat uh
so you know i'm not saying there were
any terrible sanctions obviously but i
i thought about that and i guess i
decided well
i still think this is the right thing to
do and if i'll i'll put up with that if
it happens and
one or two friends were clearly
uncomfortable with that
decision but you know that was pretty
minor compared to
the historical examples that we've been
talking about
but other issues that we have around too
like
global poverty and what we ought to be
doing about that is
is another question where people i think
can have have the opportunity to take a
stand on what's the right thing to do
now
climate change would be a third question
where again
people are taking a stand i you know
look at greta tunberg there and
say well i think it must have taken a
lot of courage for a school girl to
to say i'm going to go on strike about
climate change and
see what happened yeah especially in
this divisive world she gets
exceptionally huge amounts of support
and hatred both that's right it's a very
difficult for a teenager to operate in
you